ever since I was a little boy I've sung
really really high for me when I'm
singing I'm most free there is such a
joy I can't even describe it to get up
and share my myself with the audience
it is one of the most amazing feelings
[Music]
[Music]
when I was growing up I always sang in a
soprano section of the choir at church I
was made fun of a lot because I sang
really high and I was always made fun of
because I sang like a girl but it never
stopped me from doing the thing I loved
I've always known that I was supposed to
be a singer when my voice did change I
kept my soprano range I just didn't know
what the term for my voice type was
called I got to college and I sang for
my teacher and she says well you're a
countertenor and I said oh that's the
word for it
[Music]
[Applause]
when we talk about male voices we are
talking about voices that range from the
lowest voice which would be the bass
bass baritone baritone a lyric baritone
you have a tenor oak contra which is a
high tenor and then you have a counter
tenor for some characters it is a
falsetto and for some of us we are
singing without real voices for me I'm
singing with the fullness of my range my
voice sits very high and it's most
comfortable when it's high a lot of the
music that I sing today is repertoire
that comes from music that was
originally written for castrati the
castrati were males who were castrated
which means that they were not allowed
to go through puberty so that they
wouldn't lose the ability to sing very
very high and it was done because there
was a prohibition on women singing in
church so there's a dark side to it but
fortunately all that stopped and now we
have the counter tone of voice which
goes and sings a lot of that music there
are very very few of us in the world and
so we are in high demand 2011 was my
first professional gig on stage and then
since then I've gone on to do so many
other things had sung at the Barbican in
London England I've sung at the few
harmonii in Paris I've sung all over the
world my life has been a story it's a
dream that I could have never imagined
[Music]
I'm a multi-dimensional person therefore
my sound is multi-dimensional it has
variations in it I have roots in the
church and I have roots with hearing
beautiful jazz and R&B and blues when I
started singing classical music one of
the things that was a challenge for me
was to kind of let go of the gospel let
go of the jazz because I was such a part
of who I was and still am but then along
the way I also wanted to pay homage to
my roots and then it became a part of
this intricate woven tapestry that is my
life and I've been able to incorporate
so much of what I heard into my
classical music
[Music]
I'm really proud of my work and I'm so
thankful for every opportunity that I've
been given to shine
[Music]
[Music]